nos piden resolver la ecuación 3 + la
raíz principal de 5 x 6 es igual a 12
básicamente la estrategia para resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones es dejar de un
lado solo el radical para posteriormente
elevada al cuadrado la ecuación y
deshacernos del radical pero hay que ser
muy cuidadosos pues cuando elevamos al
cuadrado perdemos información de que
estamos tomando la raíz cuadrada
principal no la raíz cuadrada negativa
ni más menos la raíz cuadrada sino la
raíz cuadrada principal así es que
cuando obtengamos nuestra solución
tenemos que verificar en la ecuación
original que estamos obteniendo la raíz
cuadrada principal veamos eso con esta
ecuación así es que lo primero que voy a
hacer es dejar del lado izquierdo solo
este radical y para eso me voy a
deshacer de este 3 por lo cual voy a
restar 3 del lado izquierdo y por
supuesto para que no se altere la
ecuación voy a restar 3 del lado derecho
de otra manera perderíamos la igualdad
que tenemos entonces del lado izquierdo
se cancela 3 y menos 3 nos queda tan
solo la raíz cuadrada principal de 5 x 6
y esto es igual a 12 menos 3 que es
igual a 9 vamos entonces ahora
a elevar al cuadrado para eliminar el
radical elevamos al cuadrado del lado
izquierdo y elevamos al cuadrado el 9
cuando hacemos esto cuando hacemos esto
obtenemos 5x + 6 al elevar al cuadrado
la raíz cuadrada de 5 x + 6 obtenemos 5x
+ 6 y aquí es donde perdemos información
porque también obtendríamos esto si
hubiéramos elevado al cuadrado menos la
raíz de 5 x 6 es por eso que tenemos que
tener cuidado con las soluciones que
obtengamos y cerciorarnos que funciona
cuando en la ecuación original tomamos
la raíz cuadrada principal tenemos
entonces 5 x + 6 del lado izquierdo y
del lado derecho tenemos 81 y esta es
una ecuación lineal común y corriente
despejamos 5x restando 6 del lado
izquierdo y 6 del lado derecho 6 y menos
seis se cancela nos queda 5x del lado
izquierdo del lado derecho nos queda 81
675 ahora dividimos ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 5 del lado izquierdo 5 y
5 se cancelan nos queda x es igual a 75
entre 5 esto es igual aquí
si 5 por 10 50 5 por 5 25
así es que efectivamente x es igual a 15
ahora para este x igual a 15 tenemos que
cerciorarnos que funciona para la
ecuación original pudiera ser que esta
es la solución
considerando menos la raíz de 5 x 6
verifiquemos entonces que funciona para
la raíz cuadrada principal la raíz
positiva sustituyendo nuestra solución
en la ecuación original tenemos 3 por la
raíz cuadrada principal de 5 por 15 75 +
6 sólo sustituye el valor de 15 en la
ecuación original y esto tiene que ser
igual a 12 por lo cual tenemos que tres
más la raíz cuadrada principal de 81 es
igual a 12 la raíz cuadra principal de
81 es 9 por lo cual nos queda 39 igual a
12 2 igual a 12 entonces tenemos la
certeza de que esta es una solución
adecuada